joining us here is new orleans saints
quarterback on the mercedes-benz vans
phone line taysom hill how you doing
taysom
i'm great uh thanks for having me rich
absolutely i knew you you know you
reached out you're like look i want to
come on your show and i want to talk
about how i dominated tom brady so the
floor is yours taysom go for it
that sounds like me
[Applause]
yeah i know it's out of character i
guess right yeah that that was a that
was a bucket list type of type of game
you know you think about as a kid
growing up playing sunday night football
against
uh you know tom brady look shoot i i've
been watching tom since i was a little
kid so
um
man that was that was a a big game a fun
game um and obviously uh such a such a
great team effort that we were able to
come away with a win
so i i i did you get a chance to tell
tom
that
tased him or just that just wasn't the
right moment right no obviously you know
tom tom coming to the division uh last
year i'd seen him multiple times and uh
he he knows i'm a fan and grew up
watching him as you know i'm sure
everyone else in the league can can say
the same thing but um
you know i've been able to express that
to him and um
you know so this this wasn't the first
time that that i had seen him obviously
the first time a gun had to hit against
him
in this role but um
yeah i mean it was it was a lot of fun
and obviously must uh win or necessary
win i mean that was huge what was it
like in the locker room after that nine
nothing win
jason
um
yeah i mean look we overcame a lot that
week losing losing sean and a lot of
people had to step up and
um you know it was a total team effort
and that's kind of what we talked about
that whole week that's what we talked
about in the locker room
on sunday night and i think everyone
everyone felt that um and the
celebration um
was
was conducive to that um so as as you
would expect i think
you know we all we all celebrated we all
had fun but we're also aware of our
situation that you know at this point
every game is is a playoff game for us
and
we've got to continue to put our best
foot forward and and make sure that that
we
you know handle our business so we can
you know just create an opportunity to
make the postseason and and that's where
i kind of want to linger a little bit in
our conversation here taysom hill is
that you know obviously
starting last year it was in place of an
injured drew brees
and now starting here you are the man
and with a lot of hopes on your
shoulders and also you know your finger
which we'll get to in a second um how do
you handle that obviously this is what
you live for this is why you play the
game but now you're in it so what do you
think about that taysom hill well it's a
good question i i think it's important
that um
especially for me like my role here in
new orleans has been so unique through
the years and um
and i think maybe historically i've kind
of looked into it you know where you
kind of almost psyche yourself out a
little bit i can tell you last year
stepping in as a backup knowing that
drew was was you know getting ready to
to come back and make this playoff run
you kind of just have this mindset as a
backup that like man i just i don't want
to mess this up um
and as you alluded to it's a totally
different mindset right now than it was
last year for me and so
um you know as as we go through game
plans all that stuff like i've become
much more involved than expressing my
opinion and what i like and dislike and
you know all that stuff um because at
the end of the day
you know you you have to create
opportunities for
the team to win and
i think you need to understand
the game plan and you know what it's
going to take
to win each game because each week it's
it's different um
and uh you know so it's a different
beast but
as i alluded to earlier it's for me it's
been all about taking advantage of what
whatever the opportunity is for me and
this just happens to be the one right
now and i feel for you because your head
coach unfortunately is a wallflower who
doesn't know anything about confidence
oh wait a minute he's exact opposite my
bad uh what is your conversation with
sean payton like now
in this um
yeah you're talking with him out with
coven and stuff no just in general um
forget about the covet because clearly
you know he's going to come back from it
and you'll get him back and
but the fact that you were handed the
reins by him pre-covered the whole
conversation about like you're the guy
like what does he say what are those
conversations between the two of you
like there on that phone you know
honestly they they uh they were brief
this time you know sean and i have had
uh many conversations throughout the
years and
you know honestly the one that i that i
had with him a few weeks ago telling me
that
i was going to go was probably one of
the
conversations that was most brief
really and he just told me that hey
you're the guy like you know you're
going this week and um
you know let let's go and
it's time um
and and that was really it um and then
we just we started working that's it
there was
i guess that's for the movies the other
way right
we sit down but i mean i guess as they
say in the nfl it is what it is and what
you've been doing last couple weeks has
been terrific especially since when i
saw your finger and it looked a lot
similar to russell wilson's that
required surgery i thought oh
there goes that opportunity uh take some
hill walk me through what what happened
with your finger and why you're able to
continue to play with it yeah so it it
is the same injury from from my
understanding as russ it's just in the
joint above where his was so
um mine is right at the tip tip of your
finger on on my middle finger where if
it would have been a joint lower as
russ's was then you know i would have
been in big trouble um
so
i i basically uh ruptured the flexor
tendon in the very tip of my middle
finger and so i can't extend
um
my finger straight
and so we we splinted it
we chose not to do
uh surgery and we're just going to keep
it splinted for eight weeks and that
should allow enough time for the tendon
to heal
in the meantime
as i mentioned it's it's splinted so it
obviously creates a little um
limitations of me you know gripping the
ball throwing the ball um
you know that that type of deal but
you know our trainers have been great
here they've created so many options for
me and
different things for me to try that
creates you know the best scenario for
me to do what i i need to do and you
know we we've been able to make it work
that's amazing i'm like that's that's
amazing taste them there's no other way
to describe it other than
um
uh amazing that you're able to have that
so what do you wear are you splinted as
you're throwing a football or you're
wearing i guess i thought i saw some
sort of
covering in a way did i see that over
the last week what do you have there
yeah um well thank you i'm sure you
could talk to just about everybody in
the nfl we're all dealing with something
at this point in the season right
playing through injury um
you know it it is it is a little um
disappointing you know to have to deal
with an injury on your throwing hand as
a quarterback but
uh so yeah as i mentioned it's it's
splinted so we have this material that
you can get really warm and that kind of
molds to your your hand or your whatever
it is this in this situation it's the
top
of my finger
and then we cut it down and then we
basically just tape that
to the top of my finger so my finger
stays straight
and then we have this other tape that
has some
grippy material on the front of it
almost like the same material that you
see on all the
receiver gloves and tightening gloves
and that
and then we put that over the tape
to try to just give me a little bit of
attack on that finger because you're not
getting any tack with
with tape
um
and and like i like i said our trainers
have been so great to work with and
they've created so many
options uh for me and and this is the
one that i felt like is the best
macgyver or magruber what's their name
their trainer i mean my gosh that's
incredible that you're
that you're you have this uh option for
you and um
when you're running taysom hill uh now
that you know you're again
the starter here do you do you think
about sliding more because i'm i'm
seeing you invite contact like it's like
you're still on special teams a little
bit
jason no uh yeah no i i certainly i i
this is something that i battled with my
my entire career you know where
as a starting quarterback you you have
to be available for your team where you
don't you don't do them any good um
and but i i do think that you know
there's so much to be said about
situational football so
it's third and short it's you're on the
goal line or you know whatever the
scenario situation is i you know i'm
aware of all those scenarios and
um there are scenarios where i'm going
to stick my head down and be running
back and and do that and then there are
other scenarios where you get on the
edge and you're open field and
you know so i i am trying to limit
contact but um
there's there's some scenarios and
situations where there's just no way
around it
yeah i i would say so and i i saw all of
that uh on on sunday night so um how
much conversation you guys have about
the playoffs here because that's two
straight dubs you you just blanked
tom brady uh your defense just blanked
tom brady for the first time since the
middle oughts right
and um the bucks were ready to to
raise a division banner uh on sunday
night and you prevented it there there
has to be a nice brimming of confidence
going on
yeah i i mean
look i i think we've had the same
confidence through through the season
it's just
we've been dealing with with injuries
and you know obviously
every team has has excuses
throughout the league but
i think to your point like yes we have a
lot of confidence in what we have going
right now
in terms of conversations about the
playoffs i would say that we're very
aware
of the scenarios right now and the
situation and where we're at and so
that's kind of what i was alluding to
where every game for us is a playoff
game
and we we know that we have to have our
best
and and that really has been the
expectation around here so i would say
we're not psyching ourselves out and you
know
like
you know saying end of the world type of
deal but we're certainly aware of it and
um
you know where practices have been
really good and um
you know we're we're all in here
grinding how much do you stay in contact
with brees does he reach out to you give
you a couple cents
i i talked to him weekly yeah uh
yeah we talked
we talked very regularly um game plan
game you know how things went and um
yeah oh yeah so
what what do you give me give me a fly
on the wall moment here what do you guys
talk about like i know you just gave me
some brush strokes but
what do you got you got anything left
that's a that's a loaded question um
i i can tell you uh
you know obviously my experience now has
been been more unique than anything i've
experienced and so we're obviously able
to relate to each other on a different
level now and
i would say there's been moments
throughout the season too where he
he has sent me a breakdown of every pass
play that i've had in a game and
giving me feedback um that way and
um
i mean again the list goes on and on and
we can talk about the football stuff but
um you know really drew is just he
really has become one of my best friends
and
um
there's there's so much more that goes
into it so you he sends you like a like
a video a link or something and you open
it up and it's all your past plays and
him him what like voicing over this is
what i saw this is what you should do
no it's just a text so i mean
true drew hasn't been gone that long he
knows he knows the concepts he knows
what we're doing and so it's just a
quick
uh almost like a grade report you know
like did you think about this good throw
here good play here there there's
obviously new stuff as well and so
it it's also funny for me because he'll
reach out and he's like a like a little
kid at a candy store and we do new stuff
and he's so excited about it like oh
what were you guys doing there
um
he's still very much into it that's cool
and again what you're doing what you're
doing with your finger being the way it
is the only thing i can say other than
amazing i'm just glad you're not a new
yorker because then you couldn't tell
people the way you really feel about
them you know
so
um there's that that's that's the one
silver lining then i guess in that there
you go well i i feel the same way thanks
for having me richard thanks jason hill
you're a good man taste some hill
everybody right here on the rich eisen
show